YouTube shorts acts in a lot of ways
like Tik Tok has elements of Instagram
but unlike Tik Tok and Instagram YouTube
is a search engine the number two search
engine in the world is YouTube number
one is Google for people that can read
and number
two is for people like
me attention is the number one asset God
I I love New York boy love you thank you
um tons to talk talk about uh a lot of
opportunity and like what's most fun for
me when I speak is my speaking style is
really based on of the moment it's
extremely contextual there's two core
things maybe three core things I want to
touch on here one Marketing in general
especially in a B2B world I'm incredibly
empathetic that the far majority of
people in this room underestimate how
much opportunity there is for them to
grow grow what they're up to if they got
incredibly serious about LinkedIn
marketing I know that to be true cuz
this is what I do for a living I watch
it every day and especially the biggest
companies in the world are completely
missing The Mark with social media
midsize smaller or even the largest
players in this room by comparison to a
Pepsi or BMW or small and this genre my
company included um are really really
missing how big of a deal it is on the
flip side why I love to talk about
business and life is it's contextual
obviously right now I'm feeling in my
world as well with my clients in my
business events are on fire we were all
like you know I don't know if you
remember but there was this thing called
coid and uh we were locked up and it's
just the way the world Works supply and
demand and we're really ready to go out
there and so I know a lot of people in
this room might not even be thinking
that much about marketing because right
now they're just trying to figure out
how to handle the inbound that they
actually have that gets into probably my
favorite thing which is scaling you know
I think about about maybe I'll even
start here um for the people that don't
know anything about my story I I uh grew
up in in Edison New Jersey and my dad
let's go
Edison and uh my dad had a store in
Springfield New Jersey y okay good two
for
that this one we'll have less and then
in high school my parents moved to hun
and County New Jersey oh [__] I was
wrong so anyway I grew up in Jersey and
uh my dad had a liquor store uh he built
his American dream we immigrated from
the USSR and he went from being a stock
boy in a liquor store to having a small
liquor store but a nice business and we
had our American dream I started working
there at 14 and really learned the
business and became very knowledgeable
about wine and at 22 when I was done
with school came and took over the
business from from 1998 to 2003 I took
my dad's business from a $4 million a
year business to a $60 million a year
business and from six employees to like
150 and I did that in five years and I
did that with no VC funding or
investment and my dad is Russian which
means we didn't even have a credit line
cuz his whole thesis was if you didn't
have the money you shouldn't buy it we
didn't even take credit cards until
1994 not only did he think that he
thought you shouldn't do that
either anyway why am I bringing that up
not because that's cool and yayi it's
actually the biggest thing I'm thinking
about when I thought about this talk it
you know a thing that fascinates me as I
was talking to one of my friends the
other day and he was he's a complainer
which is literally my single least
favorite thing about humans on Earth um
that is definitely one of the best
things that my parents taught me which
is like the complete utter nonv value
about complaining because it really
doesn't do anything except gets you
deeper into the problem you have anyway
he was complaining so after listening to
him complain for the last 3 4 years
about business being slow he was
complaining to me about business being
busy and he's too
busy and I think about that because I
think about this industry a lot having
that Paradigm not that everyone's doing
that but I know a lot of you are and
it's because when you're in a business
of production or being a vendor of
production or doing what you all do for
a living a lot of people struggle
delegating the reason most companies
don't grow
is because they're scared to let
somebody else make a mistake which hurts
their reputation or they think will make
them lose
business and what they don't realize
often and this was a huge issue for my
father he was more worried that people
were going to steal money from the
register so basically everybody had to
work the register that was family or
manager and which meant the store wasn't
really being run but for a lot of you I
would say that
ideology is usually the biggest reason
people people don't grow as much as they
can for most of you in this room if
you're in this industry right now and
you've decided to allocate time to come
to something like this you're giving me
indications in the macro of where the
industry is and in the micro that you
decided to come to something like this
that you have ambition for something to
grow if you didn't you wouldn't be here
right or for a small group of people you
might actually be sensing that you're in
a stuck spot and you are using this as
an opportunity maybe to see something
that you aren't seeing or maybe can
re
ignite listen I'm incredibly bullish uh
events I throw something called vcon
which is from my be friends thank you
you know that's a $10 million production
so I went from not knowing any of this
stuff to like Jesus the [__] you do is
intense and I have a lot of
respect I really want to talk about this
for two more minutes and I'm going to
move on I
couldn't be more fascinated by people in
growth moments which is 100% what's
happening in the macro in this industry
right now without knowing everybody's
individual
business in the two crucial mistakes
that the majority of this room is going
to do which won't allow them to double
their business in the next three years
which should be on the table for most of
you actually this is a better question
how many people by show of hands would
be open to doubling their business in
the next three years let me just look
who doesn't want to raise your hand cuz
that's real okay good all right so seems
like most of you want to there's
literally only two things that are
stopping you one your ideology which is
actually believe it or not stick with me
here it's wrapped up in your ego you
enjoy the thought that you do it better
than anyone else which is why you're
actually not
delegating you literally don't even see
it it's in your subconscious that
there's this insecurity Because by the
way that's what ego is
ego is just insecurity with some makeup
on your insecurity that somebody might
actually do what you love doing and you
feel that you're good at better than you
do
it or your pride in your craft which is
absolutely blended with your deep love
of your clients and wanting to deliver
for them these are things that are
intermixed you can absolutely want to
deliver an incredible product build a
great reputation most of you build
something on the fact of doing it
yourself it went well they recommended I
I don't know if you guys can see this I
get the Goosebumps on this one because I
come from this I watched what my father
was doing every day and I understood but
I understood how much that didn't allow
us to grow if you were stock in the
shelves and bringing up the person at
the register and buying the stuff you
weren't growing too many of you if not
all of you that how many people here own
their business raise your hands
everybody who just raised their hand
right now is doing two things one doing
too much dumb
[__] that they should hire for and two
their meetings are twice as long as
they're supposed to be everybody here
has hour meetings that are actually 30
minute meetings two-hour meetings that
are actually an hour and so if literally
you know I come to this and I'm like
this is business we can be talking about
a lot of things but we're talking about
business today it is incredibly obvious
to me in service production event
businesses that this is the poison the
other poison
is you want as much profit as possible
to buy [__] and not reinvested in your
business most of you are crying about
too much business too much business and
the answer is to hire people but you
don't want to hire people because you
want the profit to buy a
watch
so I kind of weirdly feel like I should
leave
now because it scares me and excites me
at the same time how how much just those
two things if I could literally just get
one more time how many people own their
business and how many people feel like
they're in a spot right now where they
have too much business even that they
can't take everything just raise your
hands too much business oh this is good
one more time because I made some
assumptions and now I'm getting excited
because it gets me to talk about
something else how many people here feel
like they have too much right now and so
they can't take on more raise your hands
high don't be this why you embarrassed
this is the best great so that small
group literally the only thing you need
to do is actually leave do not listen to
the rest of my Kino and go hire
someone real talk it is the number one
mistake of small business small
businesses do not hire enough in moments
of
growth so I I challenge you to marinate
with that find your version of what I'm
saying but I promise you you will be
flabbergasted because remember I
understand what people worry about you
may overhire ahead of bit business slows
down you can fire people
you know it's not fun you don't want to
it's not like we're hiring with the
intent to fire we're not trying to hurt
anybody but the hesitation to hire is
fascinating and by the way let me give
you a really good Insight I am standing
on this stage predominantly because of
emotional intelligence and the luck of
the draw of good intuition and things
that were given to me the night my
parents decided to have
sex but even with all of that the amount
of times I hired poorly is
staggering it's just real and I just
want to remind people hiring is
guessing firing is
knowing and the one in between is
probably going to be the most
important hire fast a lot of you are
trying to be perfect with the hire
because you're scared and I get it you
make a mistake she or he makes a mistake
the project gets I get it I I hope
everyone understands I'm coming here I'm
not an author I'm not a motivational
speaker I run a 2,000 person Global
agency that I started 14 years ago that
does $350 million in revenue and I
started it 14 years ago coming from the
wine business in on Madison Avenue I'm
an operator these first 15 minutes have
not been about marketing it's not been
about like
psychology I'm talking to you about
operating a business I'm telling you
right now please do not let this era
that clearly has a lot of demand in it
I'm looking at macro Trends there is an
extraordinary amount of man for events
and it will
continue and please
don't you got to
go please please please don't go and
miss this moment because a lot of you
how many people have been doing this for
more than 15 years raise your hands
perfect you all know it goes it it's
waves and if you don't catch the waves
when they're right you're leaving a lot
of upside you were all in the in the
beginning we've been in now for 6 to 12
months but we're here these next 3 to 5
years are very fruitful you can expand
seem like a lot of you wanted to you
don't have enough
employees I'm telling you you don't and
here's a big
one this is very important and will
really help a lot of you how many people
here feel that if they decided to go to
sleep for 3 months that they have a
number two and [__] will be okay raise
your hand
let's clap it up for these 11
people and who and who does not feel
that way raise your
hands my friends let me tell you
something that I'm very passionate about
if I can get all of you to leave here
and remember this part of the talk and
make a commitment to start building up a
real number two that comes in all shapes
and
sizes giving minority Equity somebody
that's been with you for a long time so
they feel like an owner you don't have
to give them 50% sometimes it's 5 or
10% recruiting somebody the one of the
worst there's a lot of bad sayings in
life the worst one is nice guys finish
last it's taught people in the world
that you can't be a good person while
building a big
business but another really bad one
right is I forgot but I'll get back to
it in a
second I'm so passionate about the nice
guys finish last that it bothers me 10%
I'm going to go with it I'll get back to
it in a minute but what I really really
really oh I got
it they tell you not to work with
friends and family I stand here today as
someone who lives it but more
importantly has invested in over a
thousand businesses his life analyze
business the way people analyze movies
and sports it's my hobby I couldn't be
more bullish hiring friends and family
it's hard you as the person that's doing
the hiring have to make a commitment to
the relationship more than the money in
your pocket which I know does not come
natural to
most but for all the people that just
raised their hand and don't have a
number two you are uncomfortably
vulnerable and so I beg you to walk out
of here and start the strategy of how
you're going to do that do you have a
friend or best friend or family member
who might not love what they do and
should you have a talk with them and
maybe
joining do you have someone that's been
with you for a while and do you take the
next step Maybe before you give the
equity maybe you don't have to give the
equity but you need to change your
Dynamic with that a lot of you take your
number two for
granted business owners are very good
thinking that the number two is just
going to work for them forever just
because they pay them so please please
leave here a lot with number two now
what really just excited me a few
minutes ago was how many people didn't
say what I thought was may be happening
which is too much business which then
allows me to segue into something I'm
incredibly passionate about which is is
how you all get your business my belief
is that every single company in this
room should be posting on LinkedIn three
times a
day just
LinkedIn three times a day there is a
good chance that more than half this
room has never posted on
LinkedIn and it's probably higher than
50% so let me tell you what I'm
referring
to I believe that this is the most
important the advice on Earth for
business I also know that the majority
of our attention which to remind
everybody how you sell [__] you need
someone's attention you tell them and
then they decide if they want to buy it
or not that for every person in this
room the only currency that they need to
be chasing on a da today basis is the
attention of potential decision makers
for their
business attention is the thing I've
been chasing my whole life even when I
started in Edison New Jersey my first
business was a eliminate
stand I had this Epiphany on stage
similar to that weird thing I just did
there with trying to remember I actually
in the middle of my speech stopped 10 12
years ago early in my speaking career
and realized that I was very weird with
my lemonade stand because I was telling
a story about my lemonade and I realized
I don't even remember selling any
lemonade and I used to think it was just
because it was 100 years ago but it
wasn't it's because when I sold
lemonade I spent my entire day walking
up and down the streets of Oak Tree Road
in Tingley Lane in Edison New Jersey
and literally would sit there and watch
Cars drive by to try to figure out what
tree or what post to put my lemonade
sandson I later did that the way I built
out my baseball card tables I would
analyze and then I really changed my
dad's business long before I did
internet and marketing just by REM
merchandising the store just watching
every person that walked into the store
where they would go why would they go
there and I changed the traffic flow and
made people walk into the things I
wanted to sell them I was doing this as
a teenager this was not something I
learned in college this was intuitive to
me today I do it professionally what I
do for a living is I day trade attention
every day I wake up and I think about
what on social media organically can
reach people what can reach people on
social media with paid media for my
biggest clients I convince them and push
them to understand why the Super Bowl is
the only television ad that's good cuz
all of you want to watch that commercial
why banner ads on websites are complete
garbage none of you have clicked one in
a 100 [__]
years and more importantly what videos
pictures and all the science behind the
art is required to compete I can tell
you as we sit here today that LinkedIn
for anybody here who's never posted once
and never created a business account for
your business on LinkedIn that your
first post if the post is good and we'll
get into that in a minute can reach tens
of thousands of people it's the business
version of Tik Tok many of you at this
point have probably been affected by
somebody in your life probably someone
quite young cousin niece nephew someone
like that who literally posted one Tik
Tok and got a million
views LinkedIn doesn't have that extreme
it's highly unlikely that anybody here
on their first 10 posts just get a
million view excuse me a million views
but it is staggering how many people
here within their first 10 posts on
LinkedIn can have business development
and get inbound for working together or
working for an event for
me I love selling I love being a
Salesman but selling and being a
Salesman is always the thing I most try
not to do the most interesting thing is
to be a marketer and a brander and let
the selling come to
you and so when people when I talk about
LinkedIn and started two four years ago
because I started seeing that it started
to act more more like Facebook than the
LinkedIn that we all grew up with when I
was like you need to mark it on LinkedIn
people were like got it and what they
thought I was saying was go spam people
and message
them what I was saying was make content
and let it show up in the feed if you
were to start making content and not
every piece of content needs to be a
commercial for what you do though some
of it can be but if you started making
content for example five mistakes people
make on their first event do you know
how much colle the
wisdom of events there is in this room
or in your own head from all your years
you know the cliche mistakes you know
how people Miss budget you know where
the mistake is you know what's valuable
are the flowers a good idea versus not
could you get away with it or not you
know [__] I stand here before you with
the largest advertising independent
agency in the world because I gave away
all my secrets for free on the internet
for the last 15 years I give away my
best information the reason I have
followers and people like me is I'm only
trying to give it to you for free at
scale daily period I think a lot of you
could be doing the same thing for your
businesses I actually think one of the
biggest mistakes in this industry
overall is how many of you in this room
think you're competing with other people
in this
room I think people are
incredibly built into scarce
mindset a lot of you leave money on the
table by not referring someone as a
referral fee because you're scared to
that person thinking who you referred to
will keep that relationship forever so
you would rather take money out of your
pocket and not even engage in that and
bring value because of your fear of it
going away there's a lot of interesting
cliche things going on in this industry
bless you that
if by the way and you know this there's
a really fun Russian Superstition that
if somebody sneezes after you say
something it means it's true so I'm just
going to remind you there's a lot of
crazy [__] going on in this this
industry that makes no [__]
[Applause]
sense it's really true can I just say
the pr Pravda exactly exactly yeah so
listen I really really really think
there's some fun stuff to talk about
which is why I chose to do this talk I
feel like I had something to say here's
what I have to say you're going into a
half a decade of growth and you need to
be on more offense do not you know don't
put yourself in a bad position but
remember hiring employees
though you don't want to it's not like
you have a sunk cost right you can you
you can get out of it if you got caught
make sure you realize how much of your
non-growing is not that you're a
perfectionist and want it awesome for
your client it's that you are insecure
and egotistical and don't want other
people doing [__] of course people are
going to do it different than you
there's not one person that Banner media
of my 2,000 employees that does anything
every day the way I would have done it
it's called being a company
it's called being a company now by the
way this is why I ask the questions who
if you don't want to grow you're more
than welcome to have a
project you're more than welcome to have
your thing but if we're talking business
in this room you need to start hiring
and you need to start delegating you
need to start
trusting cuz culture how many people
here have more than 10 employees raise
your hands so for this group Culture
more than
10 culture is so interesting to me when
I when I see the hands that just went up
with more than 10 all that I think about
is like where is their relationship
graph with those 10 you know when I
think about how I took vayer how I took
my dad's store from six to 150 in 5
minutes or how I took vayer literally
from zero to 2000 globally it's because
the hour I just spent prior to walking
in here I had four one-on-one meetings
with employees I've never met for 15
minutes just to get to know who they are
and let them have some sense that they
can reach out to me if they have a
problem I have 2,000 employees I have so
many friends who have 10 to 15 employees
who really have no connection with their
employees I could not recommend more
getting deeper into your business if you
have employees and really knowing these
people your retention of those employees
is how I can get you from 10 to 40 10 to
40 happens because of your relationship
with 0o to 10 these are really important
themes back to marketing
content on the internet and I'm sure we
have plenty of feelings about that I
know how people feel about it especially
in times of conflict like we're in now
how many people here have kids under 18
you've got all sorts of opinions and
feelings about it right but in the
context of your
business the attention that you need to
start providing to this platform is very
high there's a direct correlation of how
real
it is for you to double your business
directly correlated to how much output
you put out on social
media this organization
itself changed the way they marketed
after I spoke here four years ago it's
been
good I think we should learn from
that you could what really gets me
fascinating about this is you can have
opinions about it and how many and a lot
of people here have opinions about doing
social media marketing but have never
done it you've said no before you
started I promise you that if you focus
on two specific Platforms in the short
term in my opinion for this industry
LinkedIn number
one YouTube shorts number
two okay let me tell you why I said
YouTube shorts and I saw some faces
YouTube shorts acts in a lot of ways
like Tik
Tok has elements of Instagram but unlike
Tik Tok and
Instagram YouTube is a search
engine the number two search engine in
the world is YouTube number one is
Google for people that can read and
number
two is for people like
me when I'm really researching it will
if I'm going deeper now I'm using chat
GPT I mean AI makes search look like the
Yellow Pages but we'll get to that
another time but
YouTube is the visual and the audio and
that's how I
learn if you were to put out content on
LinkedIn and YouTube that was to help
people that hire you without the
expectation of them hiring you in the
content you make you will be flabbergast
at how much your business can grow now
nobody got here by accident so you put
in work to be here the problem is with
social medias most people don't realize
how much work it is and when when
they've gone they stop cuz it's real
work my point of view is that you waste
four hours a day on dumb stuff anyway
and so if you reallocated two of those
four hours to actually getting good at
this you could have the things you want
but that's just going to be up to what
you decide to do it's kind of like
getting into better physical health it's
not super complicated you've got to get
your protein ratios better than your
sugar and carbs don't eat crap go to the
gym like everybody here knows how to be
in better physical shape but it's
hard same with this but it is a
remarkable time to be in the B2B
industry to have you know when Facebook
and Twitter were happening back when I
was really going at it it was tough to
come to B2B conferences and know that
they couldn't take advantage of it the
way I could do with B Toc right nobody
was crushing events doing hardcore
Twitter and Facebook in 2012 13 14
LinkedIn is a monster
the consumption is huge and people are
discovering businesses to do business
with heavy not to mention if how many
people here have specific targets
meaning there are specific companies or
specific events that you would like to
start servicing raise your
hands epic so LinkedIn do you know that
I run ads against employees of companies
I want to do business with and have a
stunning hit rate on it the fact that
you can run ads meaning you make a piece
of
content it goes organic and you see that
it does
well and then you could take it and add
money to it and spend $500 $200 $300 to
run against
targeting employees of the hands that
you just raised that is staggering and
before you ask me how let me tell you
how you do everything there's a website
I'll spell it out for you g o o
gee so as you're sitting here and be
like okay what the [__] did he just said
I want to try you literally go to Google
it's this site you've heard of it you
type in how do I write how do I run
LinkedIn ads enter and then it shows
up this is not a game of you don't know
how to do it this is a game of you chose
not to do
it and I I'm I'm it is definitely even
in this moment as we're jamming it is
definitely the thing that baffles me the
most that I firmly know that if you post
on LinkedIn three times a day and now
you're going to say what do I say what
do I do and we'll get into that for a
few minutes but if you do and you do it
every day for 24 months your business
will grow
staggering now let's talk about how you
make that many com pieces of content
because I'm sure a lot of people are
like [__] I've got one idea that's all I
got you need to put yourself in a
position to create content let me give
you an example I do not think it's crazy
that you hire somebody to film you
working
jobs I know look I I know that some of
the ideas are
progressive but I just want you to hear
what I'm about to say I believe that if
you hired somebody to follow you around
while you're actually working a job make
pretend you got lucky and you're now
part of a reality show on [__]
Bravo film it right there's always going
to be it I've been filming for a long
time there's tons of stuff you can't
show there's people that may not want
you to do it there's a ton to it but if
you take it you film it you don't even
need to use the actual footage you could
film it and then do a voice over of
something that was going on where you
can talk about it you could be like
fixing something film and then you can
make a video about why you can't go with
fake flowers and always have to go with
real ones because of the financial if
you keep showing people the world
LinkedIn YouTube shorts that you know
your [__] you will get business if you
get good at running ads against specific
clients you'll really get
business I don't
know I well I do know but it is stunning
to me that 99% of this room just listen
to all of this and will 100% do nothing
about
it I've been doing this a long time
I know and it gets into the things that
really upset me the most it's because
people don't want to be on film and deal
with people's comments about how they
look or what they said the insecurities
back to why you're not scaling drive me
crazy let me just say something that I
know has been working on a lot of people
and I hope it helps a couple people here
if they're hesitating to
post your hesitation to post because
you're concerned about feedback of how
you look or what you said or all that
[__] that we all know I just want to to
remind you you're not doing something to
grow your business and make yourself
happier because someone on the other
side has the worst life on
Earth because if you go around the
internet finding people who are trying
to build and who have joy and your
response to that is to try to find a way
to hurt them because misery loves
company we should not be mad at the
people that are leaving these negative
comments we should have compassion for
them I'm a very public figure I get
plenty of [__] I never feel bad for me
not because I'm egotistical or confident
or anything else it's because it makes
no sense human beings spending their
time trying to tear down other human
beings are in a bad place so please
don't stop building your dream or your
happiness or your joy because there are
people out there that are unhappy and
will see that light in you and try to
bring you down for a nanc when you're
faced with it deploy compassion to their
hurt don't don't deploy it to you be
happy that you're not spending time
doing that
[__] I think we should do Q&A I don't
really you know I've have so I mean I've
have so much but the the pillars are
there I think most of this is business
strategy and content the content thing
is a humongous hole all of you are
grossly under producing content for the
internet LinkedIn YouTube shorts and
then just back to the people stuff the
psychology the human stuff let me let me
just I'll leave it with this and then
you can jump out what a lot of you are
doing is you're lying to yourself but
you
can't a lot of you are lying to
yourself you need to really leave this
talk and understand some of the things
we talked about that's stopping your
growth here's a good one who owns their
business raise your
hand 100%
of the problems you have in your
business is your
[Applause]
fault well Gary Sarah's really [__]
up you hired
Sarah my favorite one over the last
decade people blame their business not
growing on the
president just on the record I made
money with bush I made money with Obama
I made money with I mean this is
insanity people you going to blame the
mayor you're going to people have become
obsessed with blaming 100% of the
problems in your business are your
fault
yep you made every
decision it's not your mommy's fault
it's not your Dad it's definitely not
your competition what do you want them
to do lose to
you 100% is your fault and once you
understand what that actually means life
gets good the second you understand that
you can you can do
anything you can close up shop and start
a new
business you can move to
Sweden you can do anything but you can't
if you think somebody else is in
control love you thank you
he doesn't drink water I don't need
water I'm 100% in
control all right all right would you
need water yes I get it I get it I get
it I drink water up and down the AIS we
need some water okay so we're going to
do some Q&A because scary one syst
continue giving you value and you
brought up many many different topics
that have been disc discussed all day
today and one is AI okay people say what
is AI do I trust it is it like stealing
content for somebody are people going to
know that I use AI can you talk to them
about how to use it
effectively yeah I mean look here's a
couple things a lot of you are
demonizing Ai and you have no idea what
you're talking
about the opinions about AI in this room
whether it's good or bad with you never
actually using the application in AI is
the hypocrisy and silliness of headline
reading that is the world so first stop
saying
no actually you want a really good one
that's not just for AI but will service
you quite well in every part of life not
just your business fall in love with
maybe everyone's no good news the robots
aren't here yet to put up the shelves
and the lighting so everyone's like I'm
going to be out of a job if I use AI
good news if you're destined to lose
your job out of AI it's going to happen
anyway whether you use it or not right
so how do you effectively use AI there's
this website called Google you type in
AI tools that's right you type in AI
tools chat GPT mid journey is another
one that can help you make stuff you
should start tasting it you may decide
no that's fine but here's a couple
things one AI is not going backwards it
was like the internet I did this talk as
a kid about the internet in 1999 not
this exact one it was a much smaller
event with a couple people but everybody
in that business room at the Chamber of
Commerce in Union New Jersey on Route 22
wanted the internet to go
back and I was explaining to them it's
only going to get
worse and it worse meant more technology
my friends in the same way today we look
at this device and we laugh at the I the
original the Blackberry remember that
thing remember you were never going to
give up your blackberry and get an
iPhone cuz you needed the [__]
buttons guess what nobody has a
Blackberry technology is
undefeated technology is undefeated we
don't ride horses down
Broadway we we don't go back so AI is
here and from this day on from this
second to the day you [__] die it
will grow and become more important my
belief is that technology is like a
humongous wave most people see it
especially when they're further along in
their career and they don't want
anything to do with it so they put their
head in the sand the hungry or the often
more often Young and Hungry will grab a
surfboard and ride it 98% of this room
is going to put their head in the sand
on AI and the wave is going to crush
them because your competitors that are
coming up the game or the ones in here
whether they're TW cuz it's not a youth
thing it's a mindset thing there's a
79-year-old in here like I'm I'm [__]
down with
AI whoever uses it and grabs a surf ball
will win and whoever puts their head in
a sand will lose and here's what I mean
by that it's not like you're going out
of business you know I think the thing
people think too absolute it's not that
I think anyone here is going to go out
of business because a lot of you have
built something already you have
reputation it's leaving opportunity on
the table it's leaving growth on the
table and more importantly and this one
I do care as I look around the room it
isn't going to set you up for it to be
valuable when you're done with
it there's a lot of people here who
aren't going to innovate who when they
stop doing what they're doing the
business will just go to zero the others
that do innovate and build their culture
and their team will have an asset to
sell I want that for all of you amazing
amazing I want to answer that a little
bit because you mentioned posting on
LinkedIn times a day yes you told us in
2019 to post more on Instagram yes some
people listened some people didn't I did
and it really changed my business what
do you say to the people oh I'm posting
too much and people are going to get
annoyed at me is three too much nobody's
going to see it
anyway I post 67 times a day and reach
less than 1% of the people that follow
me problem solved let's move
on right but also you mentioned like
don't be afraid stop saying I don't want
to try it I can't do it just do it yeah
but I get that because like that's how
we are in like all things like I didn't
want to get healthier 10 years ago and
then finally I got over to hump but I
was thinking about it for 10 years I
don't judge anyone here no judgment I'm
just telling you what will happen it'll
be good you're not my sister I don't
give a [__] if you do
it if I come back here in 3 years and
you're all like we're out of business we
didn't listen I'm like
sorry so you know I I this is why I this
is how not why this is how from 2009 to
2023 or I'm sorry 2006 to 2023 over the
last 17 years of me talking on the
internet why I got more into mindset
because after about six or seven years
of just telling the world what to do and
realizing nobody did it it became more
clear to me that this wasn't about you
not knowing what to do that's where the
Google Joke comes from this is about
what's stopping you what's the
insecurity PE a lot of people don't
actually want to face that they're
finished right a lot of you don't want
to face the fact that your fire's gone
what's stopping you is you're tired and
you're not passionate and you don't have
the
fuel you know like so like I'm very
empathetic to the millions of different
reasons why someone here would not want
to do it right um but I can't stop
talking about it when it's 100% true
right and if they don't do it or don't
make any change and they keep
complaining about it well don't even get
me into that part no I know I know we'll
extend it for another no really like
what I was talking about my friend like
true you know like it's it's like the
only people that listen to you
complaining is other people that
complain or someone who's required to
like your
mom like it's not you complain like that
drives me crazy like G it's so hard out
here then I'm like but you're not doing
[__] right like it's very nice that this
worked for you in 2017 it's not
2017 like that's my that that in small
businesses and this is like what I grew
up with well this is what got us here
I'm like that's
nice what do you want a cookie I'm glad
that this is what you did in 2002 to get
here it's [__]
2024 we need to do something different
the
endly um I want to extend on that a
little bit about personal branding okay
you do a lot of personal branding some
people say well I have a brand but I
don't know how to get people to relate
to it what are some suggestions that you
can give the audience on how to create
an effective brand that people keep
coming back to as a human as a human or
as or as a brand well I love sneaker
okay but I'm just telling you they had
longevity for a reason yes so that's
what I want and by the way most people
in here have had longevity for reason
it's the quality of their work MH you
know people are always like so apple
sucks at
marketing it's just their products so
much [__] better right so a lot of
people here are winning on the quality
of their product it's the it's why I'm
so passionate about marketing it's the
one place that can accelerate it you
know I think
relatability that you just use is right
it's called relevance I'll give you an
example do you know that you can let's
say you know how I said earlier you're
sitting here and you're hearing me say
three times a day and you're like [__] I
only got one idea for one video do you
know that you could say that video and
just repackage two words in it and do it
8,000 times like you just changed the
word X come you changed the word Verizon
to
Mercedes like you literally are making
videos saying do you throw a 500 person
event and the next video is do you throw
a 40050 person event and the next video
is like do you like I'm
serious like
how many how many people here have been
following me for more than 5 years raise
your hands thank you for the ones that
raised your hands
look I'm pretty consistent of the things
I believe in I will say them differently
luckily for me I social commentate on
Modern marketing principles and they're
always changing so it gives me new
material but my principles are pretty
much in place I find new ways to say
them I may change the word for cool to
LIT cuz that's what people
say but but I'm like in pocket for a lot
of you you can make 80 videos that are
pretty much the same you just change the
industry that you're speaking to
literally if you made a video that you
have a thesis on something about events
and you say are you in the car industry
and then run $50 against car dealerships
in your 100 mile radius and then
literally basically do the same video
but not like with AI and change it your
words like actually just the next day
wake up and talk to the you know the
fast food industry you could go on
forever so this goes back to strategy
and principles
but yeah I mean I I just think it's
imperative yeah and it also goes into
storytelling it's also [__] free
exactly like can can we just talk about
this for a second I hate when people are
like yo the algorithm [__] me it
didn't [__] you nobody wants to see your
[__] and then even crazier you're
complaining about something that's
free I've been doing marketing my whole
life you know how I build my daddy's
business not on social media Direct Mail
The Star Ledger in New York Times
Billboards on [__] the Jersey
Turnpike like I spent money Comcast
Commercial I had to spend money to get a
chance to get in front of you posting on
Instagram and telling you how good the
wine is for and it goes out to people
for free and now the way it works I
don't know if anybody's p attention to
what's going on in social media the
first decade of social media was more
like email marketing you had to build an
audience then you would post and a small
percentage of them would see it just
like email right you get a 100,000 you
get 10,000 people on an email you get
25% open rates D D D D D same with
social that's not what social is now
we're now living in the ticktock
ification of all social media which
means your individual post the people in
this room who've never posted once post
tomorrow with zero followers and it may
get 5,000 views
because it clicked on the algorithm
because the first 10 people that it
randomly showed it to three of them
thought it was good and Away you went
this is the greatest opportunity it's
[__]
free it's
free it's [__]
free I mean it's free I mean like I was
like backstage getting ready I got
pumped cuz you were doing 50% off for
next year I'm like oh [__] maybe I
should do that that was only 50% off
this shit's [__]
free still get your
ticket um I don't know I'm sure if you
follow G you know he just produced two
major events why don't you talk about
that because I'm sure you've learned a
lot so what you're seeing up there is I
when I started bner media my marketing
company was with real purpose that I was
going to buy businesses in the future
and run them through my marketing
machine if you think about private
Equity if you know anything about
private Equity you would buy companies
and you run it more efficiently and then
you flip it my observation was those
companies were not buying companies and
growing the [__] out of it I just did
that for my father and I just felt like
that's what I'm about that's the whole
by the way I touched on the marketing
and the culture and infrastructure of
your companies today like I basically
talked about how I would grow your
business in the two main areas that you
can grow a business so I'm good at that
I like that I'm still on that mission
but along the way I started some other
companies we started resi inside of
Vayner media a long time ago I know a
lot of you have used that we sold that
to AMX I started a wine brand called
empathy wines direct a consumer we sold
that to consolation this is my big one
so this is my Sesame Street meets
Pokemon like my Marvel I've created this
whole universe of 250 characters to talk
about the things I care about like
that's gratitude gorilla right like one
of back to why I don't complain there
are 736 million people on Earth that do
do not have access to clean water I'm on
the board of Charity water there are
736 million 10% of our Earth in places
like Africa and parts of Asia and India
do not have access cannot get to clean
water in 24 hours and you're complaining
about your Wi-Fi
speed we do not have gratitude at all
I'm sure the life and world events that
are going on right now reset people a
little bit into their grat we we just do
not have gratitude so anyway all the I
care about I realize that I'm just one
man and I've done a good job and I've
built a big platform but I'm not going
to reach all 8 billion people on Earth
but Disney has but Marvel has so I'm
building this so I launched this in nft
land obviously a lot of you know if
you're paying attention to business and
the world the nft thing went crazy I in
the hype of the nft thing going crazy
started making videos that 99% of these
nfts were going to go to zero cuz it
reminded me of other Cycles like Beanie
Babies or the stock market in 1999 or
trading cards in the 90s you could just
see that it was about greed and
short-term stuff but I still massively
that's another talk for another day
believe in the blockchain and I believe
in nfts it's just that nft collectibles
are going to be the 1% 99% of sports
cards are worth nothing Michael Jordan's
rookie card is 99% of art is worth
nothing Andy Warhols is so that's where
people got caught up if you want a quick
lesson of what happened in nft land but
for me I knew that vriends I could
launch on nft form but I was scared to
just make it a collectible because what
I saw so what's cool about nft is is it
sits on a blockchain which means it's a
server that nobody owns which means you
can't manipulate it which means it's
true which means it could be tickets it
could be truth it's going to be a big
deal once you all learn what deep fake
videos are and you get affected by them
you'll realize why the blockchain is one
of the most important inventions because
we'll be able to prove there'll be
thousands of videos of me on the
internet in a couple of years saying
things I've never said that's what a
deep fake video is you should Google
Google it it's a very big deal it's
going to make you not believe a single
video that you ever see and as we all
know we just grew up with 100 Years of
believing the only thing that was proof
was video so it's this huge flip anyway
I know I'm going on a
rant when I sold these I also sold
people a ticket to a super business
conference I've always dreamed about
doing my own South by Southwest meets
Coachella like a cool business
conference so that's what beon is we did
it in Indianapolis and Lucas Oil Stadium
like you'll really appreciate my belief
on going big especially in this
environment the first event I ever threw
was in a football stadium you know so we
did Lucas Oil Stadium we did uh US Bank
Stadium in Minnesota last year we just
announced Von 2024 because when you
bought a vriends nft you got a ticket to
three years of this conference Snoop Dog
Jess galba Drew Barrymore Neil Patrick
Harris like really cool stuff really
good event um next year we're doing it
at LA live in Los Angeles and uh I've
learned a lot about your world vendor
relations all that like it's really cool
it's you know I come from retail
everything's high pressure if the
register doesn't work you're dead right
if it snows the day before your biggest
day of the year you're dead so like I
think I was trained well to be good at
events because I'm always scared that
something's going to go wrong um but uh
but it gives me a lot of compassion and
empathy and and real respect for this
room and I really genuinely hope that
people heard me on some of the
psychology stuff of the way you're
operating people or how to strategize
your business and and equally to F I
mean you've heard about the social media
thing for long enough please let this be
the evening that you decided to finally
be committed and do it for a year
because even the 10% in this room that
will do it will quit in the first 30
days in 3 weeks you'll post 24 times or
whatever nothing will happen on the 24th
time you'll like I don't know what that
[__] guy Gary was talking about you
know you're going to get to that place
but but it's like anything else put in
the work over a sustained period of time
I think you'll be surprised yeah I go
with this saying just one more just one
more push yourself just one more time
and that be the time and change and if
you really are educated and you like
really like listen to me and start
really Googling and trying to get good
at it like you start running a couple
I'm talking a couple hundred dollars
$300 against employees of two different
companies with your content you'll be
surprised how much will come right now
uh I'll I'll use a real estate comp the
reason I'm pushing all of you on
LinkedIn is I'm basically telling you
hey there's this place called
malibo this is like 100 years ago hey
there's this place called Malibu I think
you should buy a house on the
water right somebody bought those houses
and they're worth a lot more money now a
hundred years later attention is bought
like real estate there's underpriced
deals at all times right now LinkedIn is
very
underpriced just like Tik Tok was four
years ago when I was yelling about it
and for you this is a [__] blessing
because you've been left out B2B has
been left out so LinkedIn acting like
Facebook right now at the same time that
there's more demand for events than ever
and will be for the next 36 months this
you know I I'd like to think all of you
understand there's moments when you need
to
hit this is a moment that you need to
hit and I hope you go hard the next
three years amazing amazing so we're
going to end with this um last thing I'd
like you to look under your chairs
because the amount of golden nuggets
that this guy just dropped is
unbelievable let's give it up for
J thank you you so much thank you
everybody and